[Music]
hey everybody silverhead here and
welcome back to aerobats of arabia this
episode is coming out a little bit later
than i was planning to because truth be
told
i like playing planet coaster too much
every time i sat down at my computer
recently to try and record this
commentary and edit this video
i decided that wasn't fun enough and
started playing planet coaster and
working ahead on this project anyway so
while that's great and it kind of
indicates that i'm not just making these
videos to make videos but i'm really in
the first place just enjoying the game a
lot
it does mean that i'm kind of behind on
this one so you know it's a little bit
late sorry about that even though i
don't have an upload schedule i still
feel sorry about missing my own sort of
planning that i wanted to release these
episodes at the very most uh
once per two weeks but i'm gonna try and
see if i can do them weekly we'll see i
think that's just a little bit too fast
not because i don't play the game that
much but because i'm a very slow builder
you might not think that when you look
at these time lapses
but i've probably talked about this too
many times before so if you watch many
of my videos you've heard this stick for
a long time at this point but
these time lapses have lots of things
cut from them lots of footage that i end
up throwing away lots of things i build
that i don't record plus
and this is always something important i
think to take note of when you're gonna
make videos like this yourself
i try not to move the camera around too
much when recording videos but
inevitably this also means that you're
gonna miss certain camera angles or
you're gonna misplace certain items and
stuff like that so very often i have to
go back in post and fix some small
things or add some details here and
there so you'll see me do that a lot
during this series as well but i think
the disadvantage of not being able to
see everything being built which i don't
think matters that much i feel like the
the biggest most important things matter
the most
i don't think that weighs up to the
advantage of having a video that's
actually watchable and doesn't have the
camera swinging about very wildly i
still kind of dream of the day that we
can do the approach that you can do in
minecraft and have some sort of
camera
moving about in your map and recording
the things that you build as you build
them from another perspective but alas
this is a planet coaster and we don't
work with things like that
besides i do think there's
an interesting element to being able to
see me scroll through the list of
objects
something that you've also probably
noticed and that i've kind of touched
upon before is that i like to make
certain themes for whenever i'm building
certain things so in this case i've made
a custom label called arabian and i've
put many arabian items in there but
sometimes i realize that i'm missing
some items and have to work on some
things and finding some items here and
there it can still be a hassle to go
through the menu but overall i think it
helps
also i haven't even talked about what
i'm building exactly here so let me do
that for a second um what i'm working on
is the waterfront and
that er that has to do with the fact
that i am trying to build this in a
sense that it could be part of a real
park
i'm still deciding whether this is going
to be turned into a real park or not and
i think one of the biggest
things to consider there is lag and
performance of the map as much as i now
have a very good computer and as much as
i wish
i could just make huge intricate
detailed maps in this game at some point
i just know that i'm gonna have over a
hundred thousand items in this map and
it's gonna start lagging and being
annoying to deal with so not entirely
sure if i'm really gonna get there but
at least for the sense of immersion of
this area and to give this whole series
a sense of closure and a sense of being
part of something bigger
i wanted to make it fit into a layout of
a park that i already have pre-planned
in my head and in that layout there's a
river going through the middle of the
park around an island and
this means that every themed area has a
waterfront alongside that river and this
is going to be the waterfront for the
arabian area
now for a while i've been trying to
figure out you know what kind of things
should i do with this i ended up going
with my current layouts which is this
pavilion at the end of the bridge and
then some open areas where i'm going to
build some paths now
this pavilion doesn't really have a
function at least when i came up with
this pavilion it was more so
from a sense of composition as you might
be able to see i'm looking at this
trying to figure out if the perspective
is right trying to figure out if the
shape of the dome that i'm building here
is right eventually i figured it was
more or less what i was looking for so
that's all good
um but yeah this this pavilion over here
mostly fits into the composition of this
whole area and gives an interesting
sense of depth i think
to that viewpoint if you're standing on
the other side of the river that said i
figured it could also have some kind of
real life purpose
just not one that i can apply in planet
coaster and that is that it really
resembles a band stand and i think it
would be cool to
have this kind of space in the themed
area so that performance performers
could play music over here or you could
have some other kinds of events or
anything where staff interacts with
guests i think it's good to have this
kind of thing
but most of all it provides some kind of
anchor points for the sight lines in
this area
and then next to it we have this open
area with lots of path work and
i will build this in a few minutes but
there isn't going to be much in terms of
buildings or foliage in that area that's
because if this does get turned into a
park at some point
i'm trying to
have a sort of weenie in the middle of
the park and yes there definitely will
be a weenie in the middle of the park so
i'm trying to build a weenie in the
middle of the park that could function
as a centerpiece for shows very much
like disney does it
except the one thing
that i think is
an opportunity that would be cool to try
is to see if the show on this building
could work from all different directions
i know usually in disney parks there
will be projections on the castle and
firework shows and parades and things
like this
but they'll all usually be at the front
of the park at the main street or in the
case of sea uh at that large open area
in front of the lake
i think it would be very cool to have a
sort of 360 show where you can watch it
from every themed land in the park
um and i'm not entirely sure you know if
if this really makes sense from a real
life perspective
but at least i think it could help
dispersing guests a little bit giving
people more space more seating space but
also just more space to have a decent
view of what's going on in the show
and you can choose basically what kind
of part of the park you like most and
where you want to watch it from i kind
of think of um what's it called again
the uh the afterling fountain show i
forgot the name of it aquanuna aquanura
which is something that you can see from
all different directions except you know
this would obviously be on a much bigger
scale but still it's that sort of idea
the more viewing space i think you have
for these kinds of things the better it
is plus
disney parks tend to have a very large
viewing space that is obviously intended
for people to stand or sit and watch
these shows and parades but when there's
not a show these large areas tend to
just sit about and
be kind of useless i suppose and i
figured this would also be a way to try
and see if it would be possible to
incorporate these spaces more into a
wide variety of areas in the park
and so a lot of blabbering nonsense for
saying that i i don't know i want to try
it a different way
so here we have this area that also gets
some sort of staggered stadium seating
approach to the layouts so you have a
few steps going down here
so that people can have a good view from
the paths up here but also have a good
view from the past down there plus it
gives me some extra space to place
benches and foliage and all that good
stuff
also this is i think the first brick
wall that i build in this map
completely out of separate bricks which
is something that i'm gonna try not to
do too much because in terms of things
that destroy performance this is
definitely up there especially once you
start building bigger buildings i think
but there's just something about
this that you cannot beat with standard
wall pieces and that's the fact that you
have real ridges that the sun can cast
the shadow on and that light can
interact with in different ways and you
can tell that these are actual ridges
and of course there is bump mapping in
the textures in the game so you do have
some
sense of 3d to even the flat textures in
the game
but i think this kind of thing is uh
unbeatable plus it means that you can
color each individual brick
which i'm going to use to add some
variety to the color so you really get
some varied textures so i think when it
comes to important or large walls that i
want to have some sort of brick texture
to these bricks are going to find a lot
more use
obviously at this point i've already
used them somewhere else
if you've been paying attention you
might have noticed that i also placed
these same bricks they are two theme
makers toolkit items by the way but you
might have used you might have seen that
i've used the same bricks
in some plaster walls to give them a
sense of you know the plaster
fading away and revealing a brick
structure underneath it that sort of
thing i think still works very well with
these pieces but you can also just use
them to make entire brick walls so
that's what i'm doing over here the
waterfront
also i have another thing to think about
and that's the fact that
uh you might have noticed that there's
actually a rail in the water in there in
the river and that's because i am
planning to have a boat ride going along
the central island in this park you know
if the park actually ends up becoming a
park
and this will be kind of like the boat
ride in tokyo disneysea just going
around going through different themed
areas it's not the most
particularly interesting ride i think
but it's a great filler to your day you
can sometimes use it as a good transport
to get from one side of the park to the
other and not unimportantly i think it
adds some movement to the area i think
movement when it comes to themed areas
is sometimes quite underrated
having flat rides and roller coasters
and track rides especially moving
through your themed area and giving it
some sort of kinetic sense i think is is
pretty important having a completely
standstill area is nowhere near as
interesting as seeing parts moving and
what better things to move around than
rides because you can also use them
to add another ride into the park and
obviously theme parks are always looking
to up their ride count
and it just looks cool and in this case
the boat ride is kind of
stolen from disney but i think it works
way too well not to use it
it just makes things a little bit harder
than i would like them to be especially
compared to what it's like in disney sea
because these little boats have chimneys
and those chimneys do stick out a lot
and that means that the bridges crossing
this water
are going to be pretty tall so you
notice i've got the bridge over there
i put that up to the height so that the
chimney of the boat can just pass
underneath it and still the path has to
raise up quite a bit
to the extent where i think it's not
super wheelchair accessible anymore
because strictly speaking the grade is
too high
i think i'm not going to worry about
that too much in this case because
there's not much of a way around it but
you know that is it is what it is it's a
limitation to work with i think we can
get around it i'm not going to place too
many bridges anyway uh but it's good to
take note of this uh but it also means
that this river is gonna have to be wide
enough for this boat ride
but it's also gonna have to provide some
interesting views from the river itself
so
that gives me some more sight lines to
keep in mind
and that's actually a very handy segue
to another topic that i wanted to talk
about
and that is the fact that
one of the most time consuming things
for me that you don't end up seeing on
time lapses but that definitely
well i i put a lot of time into in
planet coaster and some sometimes more
than i would like to is just composition
especially of sight lines of buildings
and pathways
it's something that doesn't work for
time lapses because it just means a lot
of spinning your camera around and
looking at buildings and trying to shift
them a little bit and figuring out you
know where a pathway is going to lead
because i think in the best cases every
major path has something interesting at
the end of it that draws people over
there but also you need some viewpoints
where you can just have a beautiful view
of a whole area or some wayfinding
points like some weenies that help you
tell where certain things are
and in terms of sight lines this area
right here is one of the most important
parts
of this whole build
because from the bridge you'll be able
to see the whole themed area so
most of the important buildings will be
visible and lining up all the spires
just right means that you can
look in the distance and just see all
the spires of this ride towering over
the smaller buildings
you can see the coaster tracks in the
front in in the foreground
and you have that one little band stand
building all the way in the foreground
giving you a sense of depth so that was
the whole planning of this area so this
bridge is
you know it might not really look like
it but it's definitely one of the most
important pieces of the puzzle here
and it's what i'm going to figure out a
lot of my composition of the area with
so whenever i'm not recording but i'm
trying to figure out composition i'll be
standing on this bridge and looking in
different directions thinking of what's
it going to look like when you're
standing on the bridge and you're
looking at these buildings in the
background how are they going to line up
what's visible what's not visible
how do you know where certain things are
so for example the giant mosque dome
building
did i just say musk the dome building
domed mosque building is the coaster
station so that's obviously enough quite
easy to find you can find it towering
over many things and from the bridge
it's very visible
but also from the main path leading into
this area in the future it's going to be
visible and also from this pathway in
this direction uh it's going to be very
visible as well because it'll be
towering right in the distance across
the the pathways so that's a very
important thing to use uh to find your
way likewise i think the tower uh that
the coasters are spiraling around over
here
the tower that i built in episode one
along with this pavilion are very
important for wayfinding too because
they indicate more or less the center
points of this whole area
and they are just nice to look at from
different perspectives i think too like
that's part of the reason you want to
work on your sidelines it's a shame to
build a very nice building that you're
proud of and that you're happy with and
then have it barely be visible at all so
those are some important things that i
tried to keep in mind and then some
lesser
sight lines are the pathway along the
river side
is going to look straight at the
pavilion here so you'll have that in the
background
and um
yeah i think that's uh that's the most
important things for now i think some of
the other sight lines
might be coming in the future because i
definitely have some things planned but
i'm not going to reveal that quite yet
just know that composition
is pretty important and the only way to
really figure it out without planning
very much ahead because i often still
get this question but no i don't really
plan ahead by doing sketches or anything
i just plan ahead by spending
way too much time in planet coasters
spinning my camera around and trying out
vague compositions of buildings and then
removing them before recordings
so yeah stuff like this is pretty
important placing your camera where you
know there is going to be an interesting
or important viewpoint and figuring out
how to compose buildings from there and
pick a few sidelines and important
buildings that these sight lines should
look towards and you very easily start
getting a well-composed park area i
think oh and the final rule that you
should probably keep in mind is to try
and avoid dead ends as much as possible
nobody likes walking into a dead end and
it's fine to have this to go to a
certain ride or something like this
even though that too is not ideal
but you should definitely avoid it if
it's just to
see nothing
park layouts are generally
more understandable and easy to navigate
when they're kind of circular
in setup and have no dead ends so
obviously this park is going to work
that way as well because we have a large
island in the middle and then going
around it a river and then some themed
lands that go around that with dark ride
buildings and stuff toward the back
so hopefully well definitely there won't
be any dead ends or confusing navigation
issues
plus i'm going to try and make many
things visible from many parts of the
park so for instance the central island
is going to have its weenie that's gonna
have to be visible from basically
everywhere and likewise if you're in a
general area you should be able to see
some buildings of it and have some idea
of where certain themes are located
which is an interesting balancing act i
think with thematic consistency and
that's a puzzle that i am trying to
figure out by doing that experiment
where
none of my themed areas are really
themed areas and it's that they kind of
gradually shift from one theme to the
other with very
small mini themed lands within the
themed areas but you know it's a little
bit of an experiment i'm still not
entirely sure how it's going to work out
but the tower for instance that you can
see here in the distance that the
coaster spiral around
is basically the start of what is going
to be the ottoman themed area to the
left as i've explained in an earlier
episode but then the rest of the coaster
is of course themed to persian
architecture and in the near future i'm
going to build some egyptian
architecture on the other side so
um i hope you guys are not hearing that
dog outside
but
okay it is a cute dog i have to give
them that but i had to close the door uh
but yeah so basically we'll be shifting
into different themed lands and i think
this river is gonna be one of the main
areas where you're gonna see that in
action as well because you'll
undoubtedly see some other areas in the
distance
and hopefully things are gonna end up
blending well enough
so if you're in this area for instance
in the arabian area you might be able to
see some moroccan architecture in the
distance and on the other hand if you're
in
another themed land let's say spain for
instance which i'm
still thinking of but not entirely sure
if i'm or how i'm ever going to do
anything with that but let's imagine it
for a second if you're over there you
might see that same
moroccan architecture in the distance
but because that kind of architecture is
actually quite common in spain because
of its moorish history and on the other
hand because moroccan inspired
architecture is related to other islamic
architecture i think these kinds of
transition buildings are going to
function well from both themed areas and
not be too you know pulling you out of
your immersion while at the same time
they can still function as landmarks to
find your way so that's kind of the
challenge that i'm trying to solve where
weenies are often used as wayfinding
tools but they often also break
immersion so you know that's a that's a
bit of the challenge
so finally my last build of this episode
is this storefront here i know it
doesn't look much like a storefront at
this point
but that is what i'm going to make it
into at some point in the future for now
i'm just trying to figure out how i'm
going to make this building fit within
this whole area and mostly it's going to
have a very similar style to some of the
buildings behind it and some of the
facades of the
dark ride building of the roller coaster
it's just a little bit smaller
and i think it's a good way to make use
of the space underneath the brake run as
well because we already have a large
building over here i think it's just the
right size for a small merchandise shop
so i figured this is probably the way to
go about using this thing
other than that
uh there's not much going to be in here
and to be honest
i've never actually made a single shop
in planet coaster so i think i'm gonna
have to do some things that are kind of
out of character for me and do some
interiors at some point in future hold
your horses don't don't
i don't know
don't clap for me yet or anything
i'm still not sure how well this is
going to work out you guys are going to
be the judge of that but i definitely do
want to include some interiors not in
the least because with this kind of open
facade for the shop building it's just
going to look real weird if there's no
interior to this shop whatsoever
so you know it's definitely gonna have
to have some stuff in there uh and
outside as well but for now i'm just
focusing on the architecture and just
focusing on the exterior but i'm pretty
happy with it i have to say
i wasn't originally
thinking of using this building as a
shop i was thinking it could maybe be a
toilet building
but then this building is right at the
waterfronts and you're gonna have a good
view of this building when you're on the
bridge
but also if you're walking anywhere
along the waterfront so
i think it's a little bit too important
to just put some
nonsense toilets in there i just have to
remind myself that i haven't built any
toilets in this whole themed area yet so
i'm definitely gonna have to do that in
the future
but this is not the space you know we'll
get to that later
and you know i felt like this building
was missing something so far i'm pretty
happy with how it's turning out it's
very similar to some of the other
buildings of course so nothing too
special happening here
but it all feels a little bit flat and
there isn't quite enough verticality i
think
so
i chose to place another wind catcher
here
and i wanted to come up with another way
to make these things so i'm starting off
with a base which is quite simple
nothing too special here in fact it's
very similar to the wind catcher that
you can see in the background that i
built on the corner of the buildings in
episode two
then i took one of the old wind catchers
from
the ones that i've built before
and decided to keep the main shape but
give it some different detailing to
distinguish it from the other ones and
yes i am very well aware i still need to
fill these things in but that comes in a
later episode don't worry about it
anyway that's it for today thank you
guys for watching and i hope to see you
in the next one bye
[Music]
you